what does the United Kingdom really look
like to get a better sense of proportion
let's go on a hundred second walk across
our nation each second of the walk
reveals one percent of our lands and how
they look from above are you ready for
the UK in 100 seconds we walk through 22
kinds of land but are gone in a blink
houses and Gardens occupy 5% of the UK
and five seconds of our war we spend six
seconds crossing natural grassland and
wonder for seven over sheep graze Wars
and heathlands
peat bogs which are carbons doors are
something else together fake off a 9% of
the nation and for 10 seconds we're in
four woods and there's no place I'd
rather be for 27 seconds we walk through
fields of crops half is fed to livestock
in June we mostly grow wheat barley
[Music]
I'll seeds peas and beans corn oats and
vegetables our last 28 percent and 28
seconds takes us through pastures this
the single biggest use of land is mostly
used for feeding and raring cows and
sheep in all at a time when more than
one in ten British species are at risk
of extinction do we need to rethink this
mix of lands we have and how we use them
I need more trees please I think more
nature would be greater so what if we
made more space for nature
you
[Music]